this Sunday could be a big night for
Beyonce not bigger than having twins of
course but she is nominated for seven
Beatty Awards more than any other artist
now the Queen won't be there obviously
but Leslie Jones will because she's
hosting her first award show unless they
got some tips from a true Pro she's
always just telling me girl you funny
what you worried about just go do it
just go do it does go be funny well be
Goldberg's
keep it simple advice for Leslie who
credits the view host as her inspiration
to become a comedienne the day that I
saw Whoopi Goldberg on television I
cried so hard cuz I kept looking at my
daddy going oh my god there's somebody
your CD that looks like me
Whoopi hosted the Oscars four times and
now it's Leslie Stern as an award show
host
she got a rube on at the Beatty Awards
pre-party et has learned Bruno Mars will
open the show and last year it was
Beyonce making a big splash
but the et CEO Deborah le explains
don't expect to see the new mom this
year despite all of those nominations of
course she was a surprise performer here
last year but we're gonna give her a
little time off this year now Leslie
told us she won't be sending these twins
a baby gift me and Beyonce don't know
each other like that I mean I mean I
love BAE but I ain't about to send her
no gifts she got enough money she tell
her to send me something well one more
thing to tune in for there will be a
tribute to eighties supergroup new
edition but Leslie is staying
tight-lipped on which artists will be
honoring the band
[Music]